hey so uh welcome to playoff basketball
huh how about this for a debut
oh yeah it's fun we're in the mecca when
new york city town square
and no bigger stage so it's fun fun
playoff
you know trey what was going through
your head when you look at the crown and
say it's real quiet in this bug
[Laughter]
you know what that feels like yeah yeah
uh good question shaq
uh i think it was uh i mean
you know you've been in the bigger
stages i mean when you're i mean in a
zone and uh
everybody's chanting fu i don't know if
any of y'all had that but uh
i've had it a couple times i had it in
college and i had it again at night so
i mean it got real quiet at the end and
uh for me i wanted to hear those fu
chants again
you know trey you guys one of the
youngest teams in the nba
did any of the veteran guys or your
coach talk to you about like hey
there's a different level of intensity
going into the playoffs
yeah uh of course especially with guys
like lou will
gallow guys that have been in the
playoffs guys that have
i mean had success in the playoffs we as
young guys in our first experience here
we've been leaning on them a lot and
they've helped us a lot
trey you know in march things look
dismal
and then all of a sudden uh you know
there's a coaching change
there's a rejuvenation and then there's
nate mcmillan what was the turning point
that made you guys go from you know nine
to ten games under 500
to a team that's now a game win in that
first playoff debut
yeah great question kenny uh i think uh
for us
it's just the belief in each other uh
coach mac has done a great job putting
belief in
i mean encouragement encouraging guys uh
to be confident
and i think that's what really turned it
uh everybody's playing with confidence
on our team and
uh it's showing and we're having fun